whenever there is a terrorist attack
people react people understandably want
to do whatever it will take to stop
these attacks and that makes sense but
sometimes the reactions aren't the most
useful or effective or prudent case in
point
British Prime Minister Theresa May
immediately called for the regulation of
the Internet as a way to prevent radical
Islamist ideology from spreading he or
she is we cannot allow this ideology the
safe space it needs to breathe that is
precisely what the internet and the big
companies that provide internet-based
services provide we need to work with
allies democratic governments to reach
international agreements that regulate
cyberspace to prevent the spread of
extremists and terrorism planning she's
talking about international cross
country regulation of the Internet in
some way shape or form this is
potentially dangerous and arguably not
effective at fighting terror of course
the laws in the UK are different than
those in the u.s. around regulation of
the internet internet service providers
privacy etc but the conversation is a
similar one in the United States and in
the United Kingdom the UK is a major
surveillance state already the u.s. is a
major surveillance state but look at
what we learn from Edward Snowden it has
not helped recall James clapper claiming
that we stopped many terror attacks as a
result of bulk NSA metadata collection
then asked to actually provide some
examples walked it back and said you
know I can actually really name any
specific ones and not for reasons of
classified information and by the way
the internet sort of an arbitrary place
to look for a solution right I mean it's
not an obvious or default place I know
that Isis like like but a no terrorist
group before is using social media but
you could propose a different entry
point Pat to regulation as a solution
after all this was a car that was used
to run into the crowd if Theresa May
said we need all cars to be self-driving
cars and completely remove humans from
the equation the internet aspect sort of
goes away I'm not suggesting that that's
what she should be doing mandatory
self-driving cars
but there are more pragmatic solutions
than more spying and more surveillance
which is what this is a reference to and
after these terrorist attacks happen
there's this natural discussion towards
how do we prevent ones from happening in
the future yeah that's a great
discussion to have I mean the problem
here is that the attack was orchestrated
with knifes and vehicles and that's not
something that you can really take away
from people it's too ubiquitous in our
society yeah so I think you know if
you're in a position of power you want
to push the conversation into how do we
solve this and for her I think maybe she
can just come up with regulating the
Internet as an easy flame well your
point you're pointing out what makes
sense which is go to the source of the
radicalization because you're tall
you're talking about knives here and
you're talking about cars and we're not
suggesting that governments shouldn't
have reasonable tools and power to
prevent terror the point is the US and
the UK have had it for years and we have
no evidence that it works why would more
surveillance all of a sudden be the
solution it's not about preventing
terrorism it's about controlling the
information people can access imagine a
future where everybody believes climate
change is a hoax because every shred of
information available to them on the
internet says that fortunately most
governments believe climate change is
real not not all by the way but but most
do but apply that logic to something
else a march to war for example a
decision that might increase income
inequality even more what is underlying
what Teresa May said here is we will not
be truly safe until we monitor every
conversation every email and every
Facebook message and I want to make sure
people don't fall for this because the
u.s. fell for it after 9/11 this allows
the terrorists to win in the sense that
they would ideally be against a free and
open Internet and of course that gets
strange because they have social media
accounts but I think ideally they would
be against anything that is a symbol of
the West and a symbol of modernity you
know what I mean completely agree
completely agree with that and did this
as soon as I saw this I thought they're
going the way of the United States in
2001 and 2002 and we're going to
continue following what happens there
and here today's episode of the David
Pakman show is made possible in part by
taga Deb the hosting specialist taga dev
offers a range of a four
and flexible hosting packages this
includes dedicated servers virtual
private servers cloud server options
they can do custom server solutions as
well as colocation services taga dad is
proud of their team of expert hosting
specialists who also make up their
friendly tech support team and they give
their customers full access to their
knowledge and service and it's reflected
in their nine point seven out of ten
Trustpilot
review rating you can now try out taga
DAB's
cloud hosting solutions with a ten
British Pound free credit works out to
twelve or thirteen US dollars when you
sign up at signup tag adapt calm /td PS
that's signup dot ta ga da be com /t DPS